ils attendaient une simple pluie mais
c'est la foudre qui les a pris par
surprise
un flot ininterrompu qui s'engouffre
dans les rues les places les villes les
routes comme ici à Berna au bord de la
Méditerranée
lorsque le ciel d'Orléans s'assombrit
brusquement l'orage Saba durant une
demi-heure à peine mais les
précipitations sont si fortes que l'eau
envahit la route dimanche la tempête
Daniel a frappé de plein fouet cette
ville côtière de 100.000
habitants terribles images qui semblent
confirmer le bilan extrêmement
[Musique]
lourd de mille corps ont été découvertes
ce matin des morts qui s'ajoutent à se
défoncer la veille sans compter
les 100
Istres selon
la blé
[Musique]
on s'effondrement de deux barrages
provoquant d'énormes coulées de